greeting some podcast Vil the church
what's happened now is brought to you by
on it
listen you want to start off the Y on
the right foot or you want to keep doing
what you've been doing
failing listen get your head together
alpha brain the best shroom tech immune
shrimp export new mood they've got so
many things to offer they'll make your
head rattle kettlebells Club bats listen
it's a whole new year it's a whole new
you visit Harlan calm right now impress
encode church and get 10% off your first
order delivered to your house plus
islets running an alpha brain contest
you get any size alpha brain you get a
little card a raffle listen they win you
get the today or the fourth day on the
experience they give you G this you get
to train you BBQ you get a year's supply
of on it supplements it's tremendous go
to Holland calm right now number two
listen why start off the year like a
MOOC you made all these resolutions
you're gonna go to the gym you're gonna
jump up and down the Churchill what's
happening is brought to you by athletic
greens if you're not starting your day
off with a blast of vitamins you're
already lost go back to bed and get the
gun under the pillow and do what you
need to do but if you want to feel
tip-top Magoo less green do athletic
greens do the dirty work they got you
covered in five critical areas health
energy immunity gun health and hormonal
support who all stays care you like that
nobody listen one scoop one package
mixed it water you're gonna love it this
is where I lived off and when I was down
in Huntington Beach this last weekend so
do me a favor the members of the church
get a special offer 20 free travel packs
valued at $79 with your first purchase
can you beat that no jump over to
athletic greens calm / church to get
your travel packs today you know listen
you're gonna look you're gonna hit me up
on Twitter and say Joey it took a couple
of days but that stuff makes me feel
like a savage
I feel like Aquaman with a ten-foot dick
anyway go to athletic greens calm right
now slash Church and let's get this
party started Lee kick this meal that's
a whole new year people thank you for
being here well this is like
seventy-eight doing this it's we always
go back to basics on the first episode
because that's what it's all about
first off happy New Year to you and your
families and hope your holidays went
smooth I put posted that Protea episode
up and I said what I said because you
know why do you guys thank me I feel
what you feel guys I thought well I
bleed too what do you think just because
I'm opinion how he would hanging out
with these Mook the laws the things
changed you know how it days never
changed some people really get around
the holidays and some people are really
bad don't beat yourself up ever since my
mom died I've been terrible around the
holidays that's just the way it is my
little daughter helped me a little bit
but uh not as much as you guys I had a
rough last couple of months but anyway
who cares about that let's talk more
about you I had a great time in San
Francisco in Colusa casino if you came
out to the shows thank you very much at
the bottom of my heart I had a great
time the second show I had the re
heckler who I had to put in this place
don't talk bad in front of my friends
that's my resolution for to town listen
2020 is my Butchie no more yeah have you
ever seen The Sopranos season six a
episode where phil leotardo is at the
end he 60 something years own and he
comes clean to himself he tells his
little undoing which he no morning goes
on a murderous rampage at the ending
it's his head run over by a truck I'm
not talking about that I don't want that
to happen to me what I'm saying there's
no more Butchie no more whatever's been
going on in your life that's been
playing in your whatever no more Butchie
it's over thank that to my man Eric
Rocha for bringing an episode up that's
what it was favorite episode was a
problem one of our friends and he oh he
says that no more Butchie no more and
it's true when do you end when do you
say no more you never know but anyway I
had a great New Year's had a good time
to think I didn't work I didn't want to
work New Year's I did my work San
Francisco in Colusa I wanted to spend
the week of my family I didn't get on
stage when I got back saturday was so
weird I'd looked at the Comedy Store
schedule and I was ready to call the guy
get on stage and I go no I'm sticking to
my promise and I'm not getting on stage
or we've till Tuesday just clean out the
head and start from scratch
I'm sick of that material and I've been
making little notes every day and I'm
getting to somewhere is it funny who the
hell knows
you just gotta keep swearing your people
every day you keep struggling but one
thing I did do a lot of people gonna say
what you do for New Year's
it's weird I think I calls the next day
and my friends hit me up for New Year's
pretty much everybody in my hotel room
was in bed at 9:30 my daughter tried to
stay up a 1-iron away from the Jonas
Brothers but they lied to us we thought
we were gonna get the New York feed but
we got the California feed so forget it
we tapped out at 9:00 we drank some
apple cider as a family we clung juice
glasses we gave each other kisses and
the two girls went to bed and I decided
to read a book that we've discussed on
here it's been years but I read it I try
to read it right around holidays every
year just to keep me put me back in
perspective and every time you read the
book you go wow have I been slipping and
it's the war of art by Steven Pressfield
I read the book again in the book you
know a lot of people gonna go a well no
it's a breakthrough that block it's a
breakthrough that the blocks and when
your inner creative battles this has
nothing to do with comedy or writing or
whatever I look at this as a manifesto
to life because you're always thinking
about your next step right you're always
thinking about your next move and that's
kind you know if you come to me and say
well John wanna open up a pizza
restaurant well two blocks down there's
a pizza restaurant and two blocks the
other way there's a pizza restaurant so
what you're telling me is you want to
put your life savings and go to war for
the rest of your life and then meet with
Domino's and pepper elves and Popeyes
jr. and little C's that's what you want
to do so by reading this type of stuff
and maybe hits a record with you and
lets you know what you really want to do
maybe you don't want to open a pizza
place maybe you want to start a sauce or
something that you're eating
who's your playing field you're playing
on your brain playing field and it's so
weird I was reading something that I
want to read to you guys that was
sometimes were not conscious of our own
resistance will pick up as he talks a
lot about resistance and what resistance
is and basically resistance is when we
don't do what we're supposed to do you
know as a chapter on resistance is and
unhappiness and this is months ago we
spoke about frustration this is the book
I read when I'm frustrated really really
frustrated so I want to read this to you
most of us have two lives all right
the life we live and the unlived life
within us between the two stands
resistance so one day we're at lunch and
you said to me Joey I really want to be
one of those Irish kettle dances I want
to put up a keg on my head and a skirt
and dance but I have two kids and I have
to make a living that's the same thing
okay what's stopping you is resistance
if you really want to find that if you
really really wanted to do this you find
a way to do it
have you ever bought a home a treadmill
and let it gather dust in the attic
never quit a diet of course of yoga and
meditation practice have you bailed out
on the call to embark upon a spiritual
practice dedicate yourself to manatorian
calling to make your life to the service
of others have you ever wanted to be a
mother a doctor an advocate for the weak
and the helpless to run for office
crusade for the planet campaign for
world peace or to preserve the
environment late at night you
experienced a vision of a person you
might become the work you could
accomplish to realize the realized being
you were meant to be are you a writer
doesn't write a paint who doesn't paint
entrepreneur who never starts a venue
then you know what resistance is okay
this is what I want to cover this
podcast because
this is what eats away at all my biggest
I count them you know I count them and
if I go on my facebook Messenger Twitter
the three biggest questions I get are in
this order how do I get off drugs how do
I stop being depressed and how do I get
into stand-up comedy and all three of
them have the same answer and it's an
action on your part
it's an action on your part listen well
it took me 14 years I struggled for like
maybe 10 years to get off the powder it
didn't happen overnight I had to work at
it and I got myself into deeper deeper
holes but I was consciously thinking
about getting off that powder you know
we all have the life that we live but we
all have the life that we want to live
you know you think about what's the life
I really wanted to live and I gotta tell
you something you know like I told you
guys the biggest regret I ever had was
that I'm a loser like you there's a
disease right that of a friend of mine
had in high school where she would look
at herself in the mirror and she was
seeing herself fat so she stops she
would starve herself she would starve
iself so much than it it was like
impossible what she looked like at the
end she had to get psychological help
and stuff with me guys you guys see some
guy on stage of the theater I see a
loser who what to prison and I got lucky
you know I got a little lucky how did I
get lucky by knowing that I did not want
to be that guy with the ponytail with
the Led Zeppelin shirt at Subway I knew
that that was and that's where I was
gonna end up my god I had all the
excuses I had everything I could to not
get me till the next level it's weird a
guy hit me up on Facebook last week and
says he can't get a job because he's on
probation once you say that to yourself
you're never gonna get ahead when I got
on a prep now when I got on the joint it
was a complete difference that's what's
going on now we weren't as computer
savvy
so you couldn't but I always worked
myself around it you know you work
yourself around it become the best
employee the guy has Joey how do I do
that the guy won't give me a job this
telling me you want to work a week for
free that you'll mop the floor with
everybody else in that place and you're
going in you give it your I guarantee
you even when you follow me even if you
rape your cat you'd have you molested
your mom if you molest somebody nobody's
gonna give you into work I mean while
you're around but if you did something
that was a mistake
listen man it's a mistake the drug thing
is a mistake an addiction is a mistake
there were all the mistakes that we made
yeah when I kidnapped a dude there
wasn't no mistake but I did a thousand
other things that were mistakes that
that along the way I just had acted
impulsively or whatnot you know it ends
it ends people always ask me how you
know how do how do I stop depression how
do you stop depression well number one
get in the show
get in the show in the show this days I
wake up and I could tell something's
coming over me and immediately I get in
the shower again the shower I start my
day put on clothes go outside see the
sunlight take a look at the Sun tell the
Sun thank you for giving you another day
I don't give you run back inside and sit
there to ask rose roots that's got
that's none of my business you got to
pay your own bills I don't really care
what do you do but that's how you can't
a depression these are all things that
require action how do I get on stage
Joey I really want to be a comic what do
i do well what do you think well you
click your heels and you called Artie no
no you get on a stage well Joey I don't
know what states to get to okay I'll put
a half a mile from here there's a wing
place right what's the name big Wang's
big Wang's go over there go over there
and in between the game trying to get
everybody's attention to say how you
doing my name is such-and-such I want to
do stand-up comedy and break your cherry
get humiliated get a wing thrown at you
who cares who cares you accomplished
your goal who cares
think I'll throw a wing at ya you better
have cheese on it you know I'm saying
but not worse than getting they want
spicy wing when a chunk the blue cheese
in on your face but I'm not gonna be mad
if you come to me and go joy I went to
the wing place I almost on the right I
went up on stage and sort of racist joke
and there wasn't no stage I'm not gonna
be mad at ya I'm gonna be proud of you
that's how you become a comic you know
how do you get off drugs
slowly you make a plan you know I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do that with me
it was completely different I'm not
gonna lie to you but I will tell you one
thing it was a slow process because I
was working towards it it just took one
trigger for me to drop to my hands and
knees and say I'm not doing this stuff
no more I gotta give myself a better
chance this is the life you know like
we're talking about in this thing we all
have two lives the life that we're
living and the life that we really want
to live this is the year that we're
gonna cross that bridge even if it's one
thing you know I know
tons of people who I well I'm an
aspiring singer well I don't have
connections and I still have a day job
sit down make the plan and go sing
always remember nobody is going to turn
down free entertainment unless you just
got off unless you just got off while
the owners gonna come over pull you
aside give you like a free dinner and
take a listen don't come down you know
more you scare my customers you know
Stanley
I thought you sang pop songs you over
here singing Black Sabbath these are all
Christians and all that stuff you know
you can't you know we used to do comedy
at a bar that was nuns would hang out at
oh yeah and they'd be having dinner yeah
they would be having they were just a
bar was like a restaurant and like the
suburbs and the guy came up to me one
day because you guys can't do the comedy
you know this is a bunch of nuns that
coming in they gotta hear that stuff
it's not gonna work
nobody is gonna turn down free
entertainment so don't come to me with
your stories a Joey I can't get on stage
I can't find the place
you go to Jerry's deli and tell them you
need a corner you bring your own
microphone you go over to the guitar
Center and they'll sing you one of those
little speakers and if you really want
to do comedy you gonna do comedy when
that show was on that that show uh on
Showtime that I did twice but the
comedies I'm dying up here there was a
guy up there in that show that actually
waited tables and did comment at the
same time he wanted to do comedy so bad
that he got a job waiting tables you
know the restaurant was right up here no
it's that place that sells the good
sandwiches oh alright it was that they
used that place if you go in there now
you could tell it they changed it around
because it was a different set he sold
it was supposed to be like that like
more of a Jewish deli type place and
then he put a setting in the back and
when everybody had their food he would
run up on stage and do comedy that was
his love for comedy can I get mad at a
guy like that if I go either the
restaurant you go either the restaurant
the last thing you wanted some guy
telling nasty jokes I got that one place
you take meetup in North Hollywood on
Wednesday nights that people are eating
and you gotta go up there be an idiot
that's not gonna work either way you
know but if you really want something go
for it but do me a favor read this book
I don't can't forget you wanna whine and
buy it used I read this book once a year
and I try to read it right around the
holidays this year I didn't read it
around the holidays because we have this
super bad thing a lot of things going on
but I grabbed it on the way down to the
little retreat with my family and I read
it in two nights and I made notes again
and and I saw so many things that I had
even been doing so I'm refreshed from it
like I'm ready to kill a guy from it
well we talked about it a few years ago
and I haven't read it since in ops we
read it but what I would I remember
about it what I remember taking away
from it was how like the stuff he was
describing was stuff that I absolutely
did and it just shows you like how
everyone does this is what listen man
when you take a look at yourself and
you're honest with yourself
you know the pain of other people it's
called empathy some people have it some
people don't you understand the pain I
understand the pain of the holidays I
understand the pain of being alone I
understand the pain of being homeless I
understand the pain of being the dick
didn't want to be clean I understand the
pain of one thing something that seems
so far away but it isn't but I think
they're just gonna give it to me
everything is at your fingertips if you
really want this is his first thing that
he writes in there that this is it this
tells you everything you need to know I
love these type of books I've always
been another biographical type of guy
all right this is what he does this is a
page called what I do I get up take a
shower have breakfast I read the paper
brush my teeth if I have phone calls to
make I make them I get my coffee I put
on my lucky work boots and I stitch up
the lucky laces that my niece Meredith
gave me I head back to my office crank
up the computer my lucky hooded
sweatshirt is draped over the chair with
the lucky charm I got from a gypsy and
Santos tomorrow mer for only eight bucks
and Francis and Frank's and my lucky
Largo name tag that came from a dream I
had I put it on on my thesaurus is my
lucky Canon that my friend Bob Bruce
Andy gave me from the moral Castle cube
I pointed toward my chance so he can
fire inspiration to me I say my prayer
which is an innovation of the moose from
Homer's Odyssey translation by TBT
Lawrence of Arabia which my dear mate
Paul rink gaming in which sits near my
shelf with the cuff links that belonged
to my father and my lucky acorn from a
battlefield of thermal play now think of
all that goes into sitting down for this
guy it's about 10:30 now all right I sit
down my plunge in when I start making
typos I know I'm getting tired that's
four hours or so I've hit the point of
diminishing
in return something we speak about a lot
on this podcast the point of diminishing
returns what you could give the Pik go
on the road from Tuesday this Saturday
but if you paid 35 bucks to see me on a
Saturday I'm gonna be dunk [ __ ] why
would I do that to you people that's why
I only go out on Fridays and Saturdays
so I'm always fresh all right when I
start making typos and I'm getting tired
that's four hours in and I hit the point
of diminishing returns I wrap up for the
day
copy whatever I've done to a disc and
stash the disc in the glove compartment
in my trunk in case there's a fire and I
have to run for it I powered down it's
3:30
the office is closed how many pages have
I produced I don't care are they any
good I don't even think about it
all that matters is I put in my time and
hid it with all I got all that counts is
that for this day for this session I
have overcome resistance and that's what
I'm talking about
and I go through the same thing and I
tell you guys every day I tell the young
comics every day this is not about being
special this is not about being lucky
this is not about social media this is
about who could do the same thing over
and over every day you were you're just
about to talk about the way his sitting
down process like who's on the outside
and obviously it works for him but on
the outside all that stuff seems like
resistance pulling all like his
sweatshirt and the cannon and but maybe
it works it's an outline it's an outline
of his day it's what he needs to do to
be efficient he sat there for four hours
have you ever sat down for four hours
and wrote no no it's very tough if you
read Stephen King's book on writing he
sits
I mean facing the eath with the door
open with this and this and that and
this I mean he's got a thousand things
also but what the process is telling you
is to say
if you read this and Stephen King on
writing a two different books but two
similar books they inspire you and it's
two great riders that open up their
world to you a full mace at work you
know when we had TJ English on I asked I
asked him a bunch of questions and he
was telling me that his main thing is
outline the outline there's everything
for him now a lot of you guys are normal
listening to this call Joe wouldn't have
to do with me it's the same thing you're
outlining what you want to happen 2020
what do I want to happen I want this to
happen I want to do 300 spots I want to
lose weight I wanna even if you write
down and you want to fall in love
there's nothing wrong with saying that
you want to fall in love just tell me
the process is that you don't do to do
it this time how is this time gonna be
different when the chick moved on it in
the head with a tomato tree do you know
his hand is is gonna end with a
restraining order again is it gonna end
with you throwing her out you know
everybody got out of a relationship and
now this can to get into another one if
you do get into another one what thing
is he gonna do differently write them up
and stick to them stick to stick to them
that's the most important thing is it
that's why I love this time of the year
because it gives me a chance to look and
go yes I got the soprano movie I did
some great shows this year we had some
great guests on the podcast but how
could I be better than 2020 I've been
thinking about that since mid-november
since I slipped and hurt my hamstring
and I was sitting there all alone you
know and you have two options when
you're in pain they had more pain to
your pain or to take your pain and do
something with it and that's what I did
I did the one-man shows at the store
with a bad leg the last two have written
have been way better than the first two
so even that's coming along I got four
more this year a January February 19
which is my birthday
I got March and April and then we'll
decide what we're going to do if we move
it into a theater and the Hollywood
small-minded lancet either you know we
have the soprano movie coming out I got
an announcement to make some dates I'm
doing some dates with Joe Rogan this
year and some big venues so I'm excited
about all these things but what can I do
all we got we're gonna do a audio book
deal so you guys should be getting
audiobooks soon learn that later why
because by the time I write it I have to
write it from my grave it's two rooms
too much I'm not a real writer and it
was taking me too long thank God my my
agent understood and we're going that
direction but these are the things I
want to do this [ __ ] I don't want to be
the best comic work and I don't want to
help make capital hard money I don't
even care about money I just want to
give you guys the best shows I can I'm
taking a week long because I started
writing another hour you know I'm gonna
write in a while from what I'm going
through right now maybe if I'm lucky
I'll put the old now on CD there's no
specials in my future nobody gonna give
me no more specials ain't see so there's
no more you know Netflix those days are
over
I'd rather stay on the ground anyway
with you people I want you people when
you listen to me to think that you
listening to a criminal or something
like that you know do you ever look back
I'm gonna obviously undo the whole name
of the game for this podcast and
everything is improving but like like
you said you had some good things happen
last year do you ever do a look at be
like okay I got the Sopranos movie how
did I do that I was I focused on this or
or or do not focus on that stuff at all
what do you mean focus why do you look
up do you look at how what you did well
and try to recreate it or be like okay I
was doing well first off you can't
recreate coz I don't know what's gonna
happen if you know anything about this
town this is a day-to-day town like I
spoke a couple weeks ago I'm not sure
with my acting career stance right now I
know that I enjoyed podcasting I'm
really really getting into the nuts and
bolts to stand up again you know I'm
really digging it again like I was
digging it like my fourth year and
business like I'm really digging the
writing process I'm really pushing the
boundaries cuz I really don't care what
people think there's no more safety then
my stand up I'm gonna be 57 next month
and what are you gonna do to me now you
know take what from me well I'm just
talking on stage I'm just talking what I
feel in my heart it's not like I'm four
I'm more Kelly and a bunch of young
girls and peanut I miss stuff so I got I
get sleep at night I could sleep tight
at night I'm sleeping my eight hours at
night so I'm good I want to get better
as a stand-up I want to be more
consistent I had a few bad shows this
year for you live bad shows I think the
second show in San Francisco wasn't as
good as the first one but that just made
being over critical you know I think I
had a rough set in New Orleans I had a
rough set in a couple towns but you know
what I'm gonna keep going to the store
on Tuesdays Thursdays and Saturdays when
I'm not in town I've I've left my
schedule kind of wide open January
February March and April because I do
have a couple commitments I have to
fulfill and then May June July go out a
little bit more and then definitely
after the soprano movie really really
attacked Providence New Jersey from the
northern tip I think I'm hitting the
Staten Island I'm gonna seem like good
wild brothers I'm Philadelphia I'm
hitting Baltimore I'm in Connecticut
well even this okay so like do you think
you're more and this is the word I
always used to describe you but do you
think you're more calculated now than
maybe you were after like The Longest
Yard oh absolutely
there was no calculation because there
was drugs involved whether there's drugs
involved there's no calculation there
was always a strategy
I cannot tell why they even tell you
that there was always a strategy but
something has to happen for you to bang
the strategy out you know so my strategy
is to keep getting on stage and keep
making adjustments to your material
every night right
and then eventually somebody fumbles the
ball
now I get a chance to score the 30-yard
line I got four shots you know that's
what you're always so something happens
something else happens they're gonna
come out back-to-back now you have to
change what you were working on you
might have to change you're working on
so every day I live on a different
horrible you know people don't
understand and every day the rules
change in my life not the rules
but the day's change I could wake up
tomorrow it could be something
completely different I can wake up
Tuesday and get a call from a show on
CBS that says hey are you available once
then we had a recurring character and
fell out we'd love to have you and I
already have plans to go to Aruba with
you and 200 more runs do you understand
me so I always keep my schedule open I
have enough on my plate with my daughter
the podcast trying to write a book a
one-man show on material I got enough on
my plate I have written I have taken the
stress off the special of my life if I
do anything they'll be like a 40-minute
a spot from the store with some
combination type stuff I haven't figured
out man that sketch is another mother
sketch guy gonna dress up like a Maura
just to show you the 24/7 effect of what
we got going on right now right and
that's basically all I want to do you
know I was telling you guys I struggled
a lot November in December I think ever
since I went back to shoot The Sopranos
I realized that I had a lot of dead time
on my hands and the reason why I have a
lot of dead time is my head on my hands
is because I have a rule in my house if
from 9:00 to 5:00 Monday through Friday
I could pretty much do whatever I want
whatever I want my daughters in school I
take it to her to Muay Thai on Mondays
and Wednesdays
and I like to be a part of her life she
needs to see me that okay
me and my wife don't need to be there
but I want to be that okay I want to be
there my own personal reasons I think my
nights are getting a little bored I
thought of two things I thought about
getting like like with Dante's doing
somewhere in Racine it at night
somewhere maybe
what's the town over Sherman Oaks right
get like some you know two-car garage
that has rats in it fumigated painted
restructure it maybe do a room where 15
Thomas could sit in and 15 people maybe
have like a little podcast studio keep
this but have that more as a comedy
workshop for young comics I'm sick and
tired of comics getting ripped off in
this town young comics I really am the
open mic process should be an organic
process I have to keep the lights on so
I have to charge you a little something
but I want you to get something I want
you to be treated like economic I want
when you touch the doorknobs and the
doorknobs are clean I want a camera
there so you could tape your sets not
for $50 you know give what would work in
the machine five hours and you get your
tape so if you come in every night
you're gonna tape if you pay the fine I
also perform you get something out of it
and start creating little groups of
these comics you know or Eric runs a
group and you run a group and you look
at each other's tapes and you say where
you need help constructively that's how
comics build comics don't do this by
themselves I love to sit here Italian I
did all this by myself but I can't I got
a lot of help from Rick to come in and
rob long and Josh wolf and Joe Rogan and
Doug Stanhope and this is to help that I
see open mikes need open my crews gonna
old tangent and they build these things
in their minds that because they listen
to all the open writers
and it just sucks I don't like what's
being done that way so I thought about
doing that I wanted to be involved the
Sun in my life but I just don't have the
time to do something like that I would
only probably be able to help calm this
out two nights a week and that defeats
the purpose of what I'm trying to do you
know I have my own podcast I have to do
my own spots again I hate feeling like a
bully on stage that's why I don't go to
a lot of smaller comedy clubs because
there's what you open like there's going
up and those has got dreams and they've
been working on a joke and I go up there
my dirty material blow up the room
because their energy levels are you know
I'm a professional I'm a professional is
what I've been doing I know how to take
apart these rooms and now they brought
four friends and they got a file on me
that's not fair that's not fair anybody
you know unless you're at the Comedy
Store
well you know what you're getting
yourself into when I walked into the
Comedy Store and I got a follow ripping
or more delay or one of those guys I
know what I'm getting myself into that
pen better be good today this is not
about the feather the sand I got my
superstitious things too you know we all
have superstitious things before we're
gonna do something you know I don't
listen to the radio I'm going down to
the store there's no music when I before
I go do Carly and I take my mind
somewhere which hasn't been in a week
somewhere dark to a story of something
bad that happened to me because I want
to feel that pain I don't mind job with
people engaged
you and I have driven to a couple ice
house keys and it's a different
experience and I still do the job but
when I go to the car mr. Lowrey like
mumbling to call on me I like to think
there's something a girl a girl telling
me no you know the simplest things the
simplest things that made you feel
embarrassed that now you're gonna prove
to that [ __ ] you made a mistake even
though it was the sixth grade you know
I'm saying like you asked her out in the
sixth grade she told you no right and
now you're gonna go down to the store
and do a set to win her back too bad
she's probably dead and buried that was
in the sixth grade she probably got hit
by a train an Amtrak or something like
that
so you know we all have our different
things I'm not mad at Steven Pressfield
because he does all those things it's a
ritual it's a ritual you know there's
nothing worse than you have it to sit
down you get an idea and you gotta go to
the bathroom take a long Wow
drink your coffee may get emails what I
thought you two doing the more 9:01 that
phone starts ringing in fact I already
said the emails I've dated I already
said it's Monday morning I said the
emails on Saturday night when I got back
at 11:00 just few minutes after you left
the house on your wife's annoying game
right oh hi we were pretty high I was
sending emails emails uh you know what
emails ahoy everybody's getting an email
welcome to new you they make sense oh
yeah oh yeah it makes sense there's also
put my plane tickets I'm all right
I had a little incident there for a
couple months oh I buy him for like next
year I gotta wake up the next morning a
look and call the people now and say I'm
sorry I bought this for 20 21
you know you get four or five edibles in
the other night and a couple bong hits
you're buying plan buying plane tickets
or uber you know I ordered a bar of soap
you know that's soap I will use for my
feet people don't laugh at me there's
how stupid you know I never want you
people to think that you know Joey Diaz
is a genius of sorts by any minion I'm
very proud to let you know that before
Christmas I ran out of an anti-fungal
soap okay you know Fujitsu and for the
defense oh yeah defense so I didn't want
to bother my wife I just click it I
clicked the link and I said it to my
wife and she's got the Amazon I figured
you know what my wife is going through
enough let me order two bars here it was
a four pack Lee
I swear to god it was a four pack got
any bars of soap I got in the mail 800
4444 bars of soap in a box
away this and my friends because now do
I call them back and get angry no I will
looked at the order guess what I ordered
44 why because it was 1245 at night and
I shouldn't be ordinary just keep
putting at the cart oh you should have
seen me something must have happened I
added 82 people I looked at the account
I told you account was liked by a
hundred and fifty I didn't know what was
what and that's what happened so now I
got 44 bars of anti-fungal so it looks
like I'm doing boxing and jujitsu time
100 okay I'm gonna be able to use them
all so I got problems too don't worry
about I got tons of problems that's why
as long as I don't order as long as I
stick the tweet evil things and Facebook
and evil things I'm okay that's it
that's it I'm okay I don't want a plane
tickets I don't have to order anything
you know it's funny I was having a rough
time with my time so I didn't know what
to do so I started talking to my wife
about it it got serious guys it got
really serious because what I usually
what we usually do is we get home at
5:00 5:15 from activities mercy does
homework I answer emails and make some
calls and get everything prepared for
the next day
then we dinner as a family and then I
watch the World News Tonight which just
makes me sick to my stomach to watch
honey I know I watch it it's 15 minutes
of garbage and ten minutes of the same
stories that they've been telling you
for the three days the girl got stabbed
in New York that was two weeks ago why
is it still on all she bit the black
little kids finger I don't know what she
did I don't enough enough it's the same
goddamn stories every day so I talked
and then I sit down and then at about
8:00 after mercy goes in the shower and
the tub is when I start writing and I
prepare for my night even though I've
written in the daytime I'm just talking
about my night activity so my spots not
till 10:00 it takes me 10 minutes to get
to the counter so I do 90 over Laurel
Canyon so I can leave my house 20 to 10
so that means I'm sitting there you know
my wife goes to bed at 9:15 so what I
decide that the other night was
the first one I came over here I know
you noticed that was here one night I
came over here they brought a notebook
that was okay then I came over another
night last week and just listen to music
and that was okay and then one night I
said to myself I went for a physical in
June this year and I got x-rays of my
lungs and the doctor came back and said
there's a little fluid on your heart I
want to send you for an angiogram or
whatever and they did a bunch of tests
to my heart and they didn't have to put
a stent in or anything my heart was good
because your hearts your spool swore
they want to tell you guys of them won't
worry you know Uncle Joe Blow 27 years a
blow there's got to be something going
on but lately I've been working I'm
taking my garlic tablets and do a little
cardio on me I lift weights and I've
gotten all my flight a fire response but
ever since like June I've only been to
jujitsu like maybe three times just
because of that thing they said to my
heart
I found you Jitsu to really stressed me
out it was stressing me out I wasn't
getting nowhere I wasn't making any
progress and I talked to my instructor
Brent I just told him I'm gonna take
some time off
from time to time I go and then do a
private with Vinny and roll around with
Vinny a little bit and I still go to my
Muay Thai boxing classes there and I
still do my lifting I just needed
something knife and guys when you get to
be over 50 your bodies don't like this
testosterone thing you know how this for
me to go down to the store some nights I
told you I drank for expressos I drink
for Cuban expressos I come that tired
like I'm not physically tired you know
so I got in the car one night I couldn't
come back here and I think last Monday
night I went to 7:30 jiu-jitsu class I
just went and sat there and watched that
everybody came over and gave me a hug
and everybody asked when I was coming
back and and I said you know man
this is what I need I need to go did you
do it
I thought about it for a few days and
then I went I made plans to go one night
and I said no I'm just gonna go watch
and then why not watch the advanced
class and talk to Vinnie talk to my
professor Brett don't go couple of guys
it was just great to see him and I saw
that they got a couple new older guys so
I went home and this is what I did this
is one of my problems that I had when I
was going to jujitsu
I started Valley BMAC and it's a great
school John bud Paulo all the teachers
they had were good but they didn't have
a daytime program the daytime program
wasn't itself and they had to cancel it
and I was starting you know mercy came
and I was going consistently I was doing
okay and then everything switched I
started going back to the comedy store I
started you know doing podcast at night
I started uh you know just life changed
so I got on a writing assistant job in
Wilshire and I said what the hell I'll
go to he and Valley I was in Valley for
three or four months and they gave me a
stripe I did well I love he gave me
child
you know Higgins is like the master a
guy but he gives like a great guy I went
to he gives for like three classes in
one day a guy didn't get me an armbar
and the clock went off and he goes off
any good today and he gave me two
stripes thought I deserved those two
stripes in my heart I didn't think I did
but I'm not gonna argue with the great
Hagen Machado you know I'm saying and
then when the writing job ended I said
let me switch because I can't go into
Hollywood every day to do jujitsu in
fact our borough has jiu-jitsu Monday
through Sunday
and I could pick my days he gives you
seven different options to go to so I
started calling all boroughs and I went
pretty consistently I love our Berto
cream by the way I love Joey Alvarado
you don't have him on the show I loved
all the people that train that Josiah
Wakefield and his girlfriend they were
just a great bunch of guys but it was
moving fast for me and I kept going I
kept getting beat up and I kept getting
beat up one day Alberto gave me a blue
belt that I deserved the blue belt guys
I've tapped two people in my life they
got one guy had a Kimura and one time I
got a guy in a college oak from the
close guard and that that's that's it
and five years of jiu-jitsu that that's
been my claim to fame sometimes I pass
your guard and I get scared I can't
breathe it was just a bunch of excuses I
was making to myself what was called
resistance so I took the stripes off my
belt I took it down to one stripe the
belt that I really really really really
am oh I belt
yep oh and I walked into jujitsu
yesterday morning I went to the 12
o'clock open man had scheduled the
private with Vinny but when I got there
there was a lot of guys there there was
just one Irish guy but I didn't know he
was Irish so this is one big guy they
were once trapped I said Amen I don't
know what your name is my name is Joey
do you my how you leaving and he goes no
no no in fact I want to practice some of
my stuff then he told me so was five to
twelve and me and him down the mat we
just did a slow-motion jiu-jitsu you
know sweeps escaping the mounts you know
real slow but I told them I don't want
to stop I want to keep this pace up so
basically mount the position on me get
your submission I'll sweep you and we'll
keep moving just so I could sweat oh my
god I had the best one of my life I had
the best time of my life so now at the
end each Oakley as usual because that's
my best thing I got is getting choked
and I said that's it I was pretty happy
was 12:35 I had rolled with him for
about you know 20 minutes of movement
and we went over a couple drills and I
sat by the side and I asked him how many
times a week does he go there what days
does he go
they told me he was an all great guy and
then he knows I'm gonna all rig for four
days and he's back he'd be back Friday
so I shook his hand I said I'll see you
here Friday you know and or Saturday you
know and it was really weird I go what
made you was just a first school you've
ever been to but he goes yeah I just
because I went the boxing gym first to
get me ready for this
so I went over there for about six
months and now I'm here and I go what
made you come in and he goes he looked
at me and he goes listening to the
podcast you talk about how much you
change your life and you also was said
to just keep showing up he threw the
words I had thrown at you guys right
back in my face I love you guys noticed
this year the New Year's I sent you guys
all a little on Twitter I said Happy New
Year and love to your family thank you
for making me a better person I don't
know if you guys caught that understood
what I was saying to you guys that
because I sit in this chair with Lee
once a week and I talk to you guys now I
have pressure to perform
you guys are my silent pressure and
something you guys hit me up on Twitter
and go hey Joey you better be good we'll
come on on Friday night you hit me
everything go Joey will come and fry and
that you were smoking 18 joints we love
you what I do is for you guys you guys
have become my silent life coach it's
like we're both out but each other out
so that was a pretty when he said that
to me you just said it yourself man just
gotta keep showing up it reduced me to
[ __ ] like I just I was just embarrassed
because this is what I've been saying
all along and I stopped doing it so now
I'm gonna start gonna need you to
Tuesdays and Thursday nights at 5:30
I'm gonna give it a try my goal is to
hit 200 you two at nights to get out of
my comfort zone so for you guys
thank you for helping me always you see
I'm saying you guys think like I do this
another Nana I get more out of you guys
- what'd you guys get more out of me
because I tell you my almost Intimus
thing and I learned from you guys all
the emails I get a little quote listen
there's always a jerk-off for - that
doesn't understand we're trying to do
here or were the church like a [ __ ]
family okay to me this is a lot more on
a podcast when I started this podcast
with Lee it wasn't to be cute what to be
funny or to be the next big thing or the
sell tickets it was to let you people
know yeah you could do it don't believe
anybody you could do it don't believe
you mother don't believe your father if
you think you could do it do it
prove it to yourself why mess around I
never thought I would be to the levels
that I've been here I did this to become
a man along the way comedy came in and
my manhood and comedy worked together
and they got me to where this is which
is here so yesterday that was my lesson
from the day from now I can't talk [ __ ]
no more I gotta back it some guy called
me out of my [ __ ] so uh because of him
I'm gonna start going to need you two at
night twice a week and that's it that's
the podcast I wanted to talk to you
people about what it's like and that's
it it's but it was a great year 2019 but
I promise you that 2020 there's gonna be
that much better today when we finish
this podcast all of the war of art or
there's a war of art for writers there's
so many Stephen Cresswell has a couple
great books out he's got turning pro but
my Bible for right now is the war of art
and there is the art of war by Sun Tzu
that's if you plan on being John wick -
part time I don't think nothing is it
John wick so knock it off but that gives
you some interesting points also on the
psychological of it but for today I just
want to talk about the war of art I
want to talk about resistance and I want
to talk to the two lives you live that
are inside of you do you want to be
fifty for one day and realize that this
is me 56 I quit when I quit jujitsu am I
trying to be Joe black milk no I'm just
in the business of not quitting because
I know if I don't quit that my time
you'll get that much stronger and I
suggest you people do the same thank you
very much for listening thank you for
being with me on a Monday 8:00
this ain't the podcast I'm jumping up
and down we got that one for you the
next two or three podcast today was just
to kick off the new year tell you what
the church is doing this year what the
church needs to do this year we need to
go out of our comfort zone and if I'm
gonna do it at 57 you guys are gonna do
it here 20s 30s or 40s it's that simple
thank you for listening and have a great
day before I end this real quick
don't forget honors they've been with us
since day one and listen I usually don't
like a lot of vitamin people or whatever
I don't know but they've been great I
love them the most because they backed
their product alpha brain is back 100%
don't even want the product back if it
don't work for you the new drop and she
send it back that's it and they'll send
you the money back don't even send them
back but that's why going on it not only
there's an island have that like I said
new mood shoot export room check immune
you know I get back into my heavy flying
season I kick up the shoot a Camille
that's just the way it works out I gotta
get going I gotta you know I gotta fly
with my wife was just sick my
sister-in-law was sick and I'm still
here why because I'm using the immune
from new from on it so going on that
webpage this and I can't do anything to
you with the club bells or the bar bells
or the or the kettle bells or I can help
you with the supplement stuff I need
food anything you need from there the
jerky the protein powder the CMT the the
coconut CMT to add to your coffee
tremendous listen go to Hana calm right
now I'm press in church and get 10% off
your order also while I got you here
listen athletic greens if you guys
aren't starting the day off with a blast
of vitamins you're wasting your time
right in one scoop you get 75 essential
vitamins minerals probiotics prebiotics
digestive enzymes and raw superfoods
mushrooms and whole foods they got
everything if you want to feel tip-top
Magoo letteth let it greens do the work
why because they take care and every
listen no more pill bottles or trying to
choke down a dozen apples it's all here
and guess what all synthetic greens us
they make it very easy use travel packs
the ones I took Donington Beach so when
I'm on the road I drink my little
insurance policy I have a little fun and
everything is alright everything is here
in plant is plant-based by the way sure
if you're on keto or gluten-free you
could take this no chemicals no
artificial flavors no preservatives no
sweeteners no added sugar no GMOs
herbicides pesticides we dairy gluten
corn lactose sucrose dextrose yeast
peanuts or animal products guys you need
to take good care of yourself that's why
I recommend supplements to everyone it's
easy just add cold water and shake it up
you can take that banana and shove it up
your ass and I'm gonna do nothing for
you what are you waiting for do me a
favor the church family it's a special
offer you ready for what it is I'm gonna
get you 20 free travel packs invalid at
$79 with your first purchase we're gonna
get that at nowhere
they're gonna help you start the year
off on a good foot jump over to athletic
greens calm / church to get your trowel
packs but more importantly jump over 20
grams com see what they're doing see
what's in their product you're gonna
love it
right now put in church and get 20 free
travel packs valid $79 with your / with
your firstborn athletic greens
tremendous listen it's January 6 I love
you guys along my heart I got nothing I
got I think Friday the 17th I'm a
Bakersfield at the Fox Theater and the
18th of at the Tower Theatre in Fresno
Fresno
I'm coming this meadow
a long time and then on the 25th of
January they added the second show
Atlanta at the Tabernacle theater
tickets are still on sale you got what
you need beside that I'll see you guys
Wednesday more than 10 top Magoo ready
to go ready to power half two in a month
it's a new year you got a hold a baby
thanks again to Steven Pressfield thanks
again to the flying Juba motion pony for
you guys for having our back to
supporting us again the church family
wishes you a happy new year 2020
kick this me only